hi my name is Dominic Millie odo I'm
here today to talk about how to map a
double cover of the complex plane onto a
torus this is for educational purposes
for our students just beginning complex
analysis
this is an education video I'm hoping
that students just starting complex
analysis can look through these this
presentation and get a better
understanding of how to integrate over a
multivalued function over a contour I've
noticed over the years students have
difficulty understanding contour
integration over multi valued functions
and some are presented in a way that I
believe this beginning students and
complex analysis could follow and in the
process of this mapping I'm going to
create a normal Riemann surface in a way
that Riemann originally intended these
surfaces Riemann's intention was to
design a new surface and with a new
coordinate system where by multiple
valued functions could become single
valued functions and we're going to do
that with this square root function a
double valued function I have a summary
of what I'm going to do I have the Z
plane here with these this matrix of
points aligns and I have over the Z
plane the real part of this square root
function that I'm going to use as the
icon of the double cover and I'm going
to take the Z plane using that double
cover and map it to the Zeta plane and
throughout this whole slide presentation
I'm gonna keep the same colors I'm gonna
the colors are going to go through
whereas this yellow surface here is
going to get mapped to the yellow
rectangle and the Zeta plane the same
way with for the green the blue and the
red and then I'm going to bend this this
double cover in the Zeta plane when I
say double cover I'm meaning this
color-coded rectangle in the Zeta plane
I'm gonna bend it into a torus
maintaining the cover colors I'm gonna
use the blue the green is going to go
through the green section on the torus
the red is going to go to the red the
yellow and the blue and also I want to
keep track for a reason I'm going to
show you later this contour this
ramified contour over the sink
the point at Z equals one you can see it
if I kind of blow up the you can see
this yeah this contour I have a color
code that yellow goes around to the blue
it wraps around the function to the
green green turns to the red and it goes
back to the yellow and I'm going to map
that contour into the Zeta plane with
the same colors the green part of that
contour gets mapped to this green arc
and the red and the blue and the yellow
and I'm going to map that to the Taurus
in the same color code I have the blue
part of that contour going into the blue
section of the torus the green the red
and the yellow and I also want to keep
track to give us an intuitive sense of
unwinding this multiple valued function
into a single valued function I'm going
to keep track of of this point this
little dot right here represents the
point 1 plus I and those in the Z plane
and I'm going to map that point to two
parts in this Zeta plane that I have
labeled this little blue point that you
could barely see here in a little red
point here and then I'm gonna map that
those same points to this little blue
dot right here and this little red dot
right here first though I want to look
in a little more detail and and and
since this I forgot about this one since
this is a training exercise for soon
it's just studying complex analysis I
want to give an intuitive sense of how
are we going to map two copies of the
complex plane into that little square in
the Zeta plane and we could start with
just simple functions P of X maps the
interval from 0 to 10 into the interval
0 to 1 they have the same cardinality
but it intuitively it looks like a
bigger set of points into a smaller set
of points in the same way with this
integral function I could map the entire
real axis into the unit interval so it
shouldn't come as a sub
cries that I could take half planes of
the Zeta plane of the Z plane and map
that into a small rectangle and we do
this with a Schwarz Christoffel
transformed it's an integral transform
for every value of Z I'm gonna integrate
this integrand and I'm gonna obtain a
complex value C plus a to I and I'm
going to plot in the Zeta plane that
value but first I want to look at this
double cover a little bit more and
remember this is just the real component
of the function it gives us an intuitive
sense for the integration and that's
another thing I want to emphasize I find
that students have difficulty
understanding integration of a
multivalued functions so this is our
real part gives us an understand we have
here one cover right here the yellow in
the blue and we have another cover here
that I'm going to be integrating over
those I'm going to integrate over each
one of those services in the complex
domain it's actually doing a complex
integral even though I'm using as the
icon of this double cover this is just
real part of the function and one
problem I find that students have with
contour integration of a multi-value
function is how do I know where the path
of integration is going on this surface
that can have multiple surfaces and so
in order to affect that integration I
want to make sure that Anna that I
integrate over an analytically
continuous path over one of those
color-coded half planes and I could do
that by converting the integrand into
its algebraic form fzw setting it equal
to zero and then implicitly
differentiating with respect to t when i
have Z as a function of T I obtained
this differential equation I set up an
initial IVP problem I start at the
origin Z is equal to 0 and
define a function Z of T for example if
I want to integrate from 1 1 plus I 0
integrate from 0 to 1 plus I Z of T is
just equal to t plus I T and we're going
to track those two points that I spoke
about and this is some code I want to
show you and I would show the students
also I have the function defined here I
define Z as a function of T and I choose
which surface of that multivalued
function I want to integrate over an
analytically continuous path simply by
choosing one of the the roots to when I
solve the function equal to 0 and for
the blue sheet I'm choosing root 2 once
I know that that root 2 is on the blue
sheet I'm going to set up nd solve I'm
going to first compute the derivative
the implicit derivative with respect to
T set up and Desalle I'm going to then
integrate that differential equation in
order to get an analytically continuous
version of the function so in that way
we eliminate branch cuts possible branch
implicit branch cuts that we might
encounter if we just tried to integrate
over the function itself in Mathematica
so I integrate the differential equation
with nd solve I find the solution and
then I'm a jump here and then I'm going
to integrate that's analytically
continuous solution with n integrate and
I'm going to integrate from 0 to 1 plus
I and I want to run that code here
shift-enter
and just to show you what happens when I
integrate over that blue sheet from 0 to
1 plus I I get this value 0.49 plus 9
seven point nine seven and I want to
compare this to the built-in elliptic F
function in Mathematica just to make
sure that my integration is correct and
in this case I can do that I'm checking
it against elliptic alpha I get the same
value
and in order to do this mapping I'm
gonna have to translate these values by
plus or minus PI over two so that I can
get the double cobble rectangle and I'm
just showing the translated value and
just to get an intuitive sense because
sometimes students find this difficult I
just show the path on the the real sheet
it's this is the the blue cover I'm
integrating it from 0 to 1 plus I and I
just show the path here 0 in red and I
want to do the same thing over the red
cover this time imma choose the first
route right here do the same kind of
differential equation integrate that
differential equation find the
analytically continuous path over that
this red cover and then I'm going to
integrate that function and I'll get the
negative it's the square root and again
show it right here now I want to start
plotting all of these points I'm gonna
do this integral for each half plane of
the Schwarz Christoffel transformation
it Maps the upper half plane to a
polygon which in the case of square
roots it's a rectangular polygon and
that's what I'm using here and so I have
here a color-coded map that we're going
to build that that double cover plot so
I have here Zeta at blue that means I'm
going to integrate using that that
Schwarz kristef I'll transform from 1
plus I get this value and I'm just gonna
plot that point that's the blue point
and then I'm going to integrate 0 to 1
plus I over the red sheet and I'm gonna
get this point and I'm gonna plot them
and you can begin to already see how I'm
gonna unwind this multiple valued
function into a single valued function
because the blue and a red represent the
same value of z1 plus I but yet they get
mapped to different places and that's
the same way for all the values of Z and
if I do this mapping that integral
function over
the blue sheet for just a rectangle from
plus or minus five I'll come out with
this and I'll get this plot and these
contour lines represent the horizontal
and vertical grids that I had shown in
an earlier video of the double cover and
I'm gonna translate that into the first
quadrant now I'm going to integrate over
that that cover over the red sheet and
I'm gonna get this and this is already
translated and I can do the same thing
for the lower half plane over the yellow
and the green sheet and I get these so
we're starting to build that mapping I'm
mapping a two copies of the complex
plane and even though keep in mind that
this rectangle it only represents a very
small section of the of the Z plane like
plus or minus five the entire remainder
of the Z plane from out to infinity is
in this little section here that I have
not drawn contours all the rest of it is
in there and also I want to keep track
of this ramified contour that's wrapping
around the singular point at one with
those contours if I map that the blue
section of that contour I get that
contour in the Zeta plane I map the
yellow the green and the red and recall
that ramified contour was a closed
contour of winding number two it wrapped
around the sheets twice because it's a
square root function and it's going to
become important later on and also I
want a map of the value of one the
integral of Schwarz Christoffel integral
is convergent at the singular points and
I'm mapping these points I'm mapping 1
minus 1 K is going to get mapped there
minus K and infinity and that's how we
create this double cover and then later
I'm going to show how to just bend this
double cover into a torus
and I have here a locator map just to
get a little experience this on the left
side is the value of Z and on the right
side is the integral the Schwarz
Christoffel integral from zero to that
point so if I move this red point right
here so say that's one point I have the
red at about one point I 1 plus I so the
integral from 0 to 1 plus I gets mapped
to this little red point right here and
you could see if I move this I'm going
to move it to a higher imaginary number
get higher and higher is getting closer
and closer to that point at infinity in
the same way it says students could
experiment with this and what I want to
emphasize is I'm integrating over the
blue and the red sheet if I put them
back superimpose them at 1 plus I keep
in mind that they're getting mapped to
different spots in this double cover the
same way with the green and the yellow
sheet there's something to play with so
I have this double cover now I want to
bend it into a torus how do I do that
I'm gonna translate the double cover
right here this is my double cover
I want to bend that into this torus and
I'm gonna do that with two different
rotation transforms first I'm going to
wrap it around in the alpha in the
latitude direction and then I'm gonna
wrap it around in the latitude direction
in the feed direction now how are we
going to do that and we want to make
sure that when we bend it the points end
up where they should end up on the torus
based on the transformations of these
equations in order to map this double
cover to the torus we let
see equals well I should have emphasized
that this is the equation of the Taurus
in the XY plane XY and z as a function
of alpha and fee and I'm going to map
the points in the Zeta plane see and ADA
are going to get mapped to alpha and fie
how I'm gonna do that well I'm gonna let
C equals V and I'm gonna let this this
integral equation here I'm gonna it's in
ADA as a function of alpha and we could
either we can even in the case where the
torus has a radius of two and the two
has a radius of 1
we could even solve this integral
exactly and get explicit expressions
between we have here we're mapping the
zeta the Z plane Z to the Zeta plane
that double cover and then we're going
to map that double cover to the torus in
terms of alpha and fie so how are we
gonna do that so that these relations
hold how am I going to bend this this
cover so that all the points end up
where they should end up when I'm done
so let's look at that I'm gonna use a
rotation transform a built-in function
in Mathematica you give it the rotation
angle the rotation axis the center of
rotation and once again I have the cover
here I have the torus and I want to bend
it in the alpha direction I'm gonna get
rid of the cover and the torus and I'm
just gonna set a set of a set of points
here a set of points in the this is the
double cover and if I take those points
and map them to the tourists based on
those two functions I just showed you
how to map the the Zeta plane to the
torus I would get
they should end up there if I do this
right they should end up on the torus
and also I have here a just to show
students the center axis if I start
rotating these points it's just showing
where the axis of rotation is so if I
start right if I leave it right there at
the origin axis of rotations at the
origin
if I take a point that starts on at the
location 3 on the x axis 3 0 0 and I
rotated by this many radians that point
would get rotated right there and the
same way with these other points where I
have a factor of the rotation angle it's
a plus or minus 1 so I can get that the
negative and positive but the important
point I want to make out is if I just
uniformly rotate these points they're
not going to end up where they should
end up because of this this integral
it's not a linear mapping I have to
adjust these points I have to use a
factor so that these points end up where
they should and I do that here once
again I have the the torus cover where
the point should low should be on the
the torus and if I use that factor and
rotate it those points end up where they
should so now I know that I have the
Alpha rotation correctly now the C
rotation is just it's linear C is equal
to 2 feet now what I want to do I just
want to take an arbitrary set of points
in this double cover and I'm using it as
a parabola here's the cover right here
it's a parabola in the double cover I
want to rotate those points so that they
end up where they should end up if I
rotated those points they should end up
right there
so first we use the alpha rotation with
that scale factor and then the fee
rotation and they end up where they
should so now that we have the algorithm
working for an arbitrary set of points I
can now take the entire double cover
including all the grid lines that
ramified contour the blue and the red
point and just bend it into a torus and
the point I want to make and I want a
better picture of this torus I had a
ramified contour in the Z plane that
wrapped around the Z plane twice as it
wrapped around that singular point at
one it now becomes a closed contour of
winding number one its winding around
this singular point at one this contour
and we could use that as a basis for
justifying applying Laurent's theorem to
compute power expansions of this
algebraic function the square root
function but what I want to point out
now is to realize what Riemann had in
mind let's look at this this blue point
remember this blue point was the
integral from 1 plus I and this red
point was also the Z value at 1 plus I
now if I associate that blue point 1
plus I as the value of the function not
the integral just the value of that
square root function over the blue cover
at 1 plus I and then I do the same thing
with this red point I associate that red
point with Z at 1 plus I plus the value
of the function at the red cover I can
now define an entire coordinate system
over this this torus made up of points P
which are equal to
a pair z and the value of the function
over that cover so now I have a set of
points on this torus that I could define
a function of these piece F of P is
equal to the W value which is the value
of the square root and so now I have so
this value this red point would
represent z1 plus I plus the value of
the function over the red cover at 1
plus I and this blue point would be z1
plus I and the value of the function at
over the blue cover so and I could do
that for all the points over the complex
plane two copies of the complex plane
and in that way unwrap this multiple
valued function so that now becomes this
function f of P becomes a single valued
analytic function of the points P on
this torus and what I can do is I can
apply Laurent's theorem and I'm using
this integral sign I'm hesitant to use a
new integral sign in mathematics it's
worked for me a lot the integral
represents a analytically continuous
path analytic continuous route over a
ramified path around a singular point of
an algebraic function now in this case
is very simple it's just wrapping around
the square root twice but there are
other functions a inverse of a 12 degree
polynomial that would have 12 branch
surfaces segregated into 3 4 cycle
branches and in order to compute these
powers expansions I would have to
integrate over an analytically
continuous path over one of those cycles
so to wrap around four times and other
functions higher functions will have
multiple cycle types I'll have a cycle
type of two it'll it'll loop around
twice a cycle type of three and loop
around three times and so this integral
represents we're going to
integrate around this path and if we do
this if we use this this expression we
can act you actually calculate a Persol
series a fractional power expansion for
the function centered at the singular
point at one now in general there is a
method that computes the exact values of
the power expansion using newton
polygons but i find it interesting that
you could apply this using contour
integration and I want to compare that
I'm I computed the first tenth on the
first 10 terms of this series
using these contour integrals and I want
to compare it to the value of this
function the original function where
I've included some constants 8 and to
see that we get the same value this
value right here and for those of you
who are interested in more about this I
have a website I'm going to click it
here called algebraic functions and it
goes over a lot of this plotting
algebraic functions applying Laurent's
and the residue theorem in a complex
analysis you don't normally encounter
using the residue theorem for an
algebraic function like a square root
function if I had a mere amorphic
function I'd have a pole with a residue
well algebraic functions have residues
also and you could apply the residue
theorem to algebraic functions using
those expressions and also have a
summary of using Newton polygons to
compute these power expansions ok
thank you guys for coming